JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right.
So joining me here-- hopefully
this dock is going to update,
and I'll find out what we're
actually talking about.
ALEX RUSSELL: Just make it up.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I am going
to have to make it up.
This dock is not updating.
It updated on the tablet, so
let's switch to that instead.
Always have a backup.
All right, so joining
me on the panel today,
we've got-- where is
he-- Alex Russell, right?
You saw him yesterday
talking about the web
apps and the Service Worker.
Mike Tsao, who is the engineer
on Chrome apps and extensions.
Adrienne Porter Felt, who
spoke yesterday on permissions.
Alex Komoroski,
who is the product
manager on Polymer and Blink.
Greg Simon, right
at the end there,
engineering director of Chrome.
And Andrew Grieve,
engineer on Cordova, right?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool.
I noticed, when I was writing
down all the names for this,
is that almost everyone's
name here begins with A.
And I'm starting to feel
like Google assigns jobs
based on alliteration.
Alex, Adrienne, Alex, Andrew,
you work on apps, you see.
And we got Paul Lewis.
Paul works on performance.
Matt works on material design.
Jake, just be happy with a job.
[LAUGHTER]
So, yeah, we're here to talk
about the future of apps.
We've got some questions
already that you've
been submitting
to the moderator.
But keeping them coming in
via the details on the screen.
There's the hashtag, the Twitter
account on the moderated panel.
And hopefully, this talk
will be updated live.
So first up, to kind of start us
off, what is a web app and why?
Alex, do you want
to start with that?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Sure.
So I think people have this
difference between sites, which
are more static
content, and apps
which feel more
like native things.
In our perspective,
it's actually
much more of a spectrum.
So you can apply the
labels wherever you want.
But ultimately, different
types of use cases
are going to have different
sweet spots for it.
So something that's more like
an app will work offline,
will have things like
push notifications
and that kind of stuff.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you
would say, at the moment,
there on no web apps, then?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Ooh,
that's a good point.
I think that you can still
have an app experience,
and you can use stuff
that exists today
to make something that's
as good as you can.
So one of the things that's
important to emphasize,
too, I think, and one of the
reasons why it makes sense
to do a web app is what
Darin talked about yesterday,
I think.
On native, you see that users
are using like 12 apps a month.
Now this is great if you're
one of those 12 apps.
But if you aren't, how are you
going to get to your users?
How are you going to get people
to actually use your thing?
And so the web is this great
way to reach your users,
with zero friction.
So you want to give the
best experience you can,
be the on-ramp.
And maybe, if you build a
really strong relationship
with your users, you'll
convince them to install, maybe,
your native app.
Or maybe you won't need to if
you built a strong enough web
experience.
So I think that's one
of the reasons why
it makes so much sense to really
be trying to make your web
experience as strong as you can.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What would
you-- give us an example.
GREG SIMON: Is this on?
Testing.
No?
Yep.
Just piling on what Alex
said, the first time
that the bit flipped in my
head, this is a web app,
was when I first used Gmail
in, I think, 2002 or 2003.
I can't remember when.
I was like, holy moly, like
this is-- it's not just
reloading every time I click.
Of course, it's loading, but
it's not-- I don't see it.
It was just magical.
And that was when the
bit flipped for me
about the web apps.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So is that kind
of the seamlessness of one page
doing all of the interacting
that gave it the app feel?
GREG SIMON: Well, it was that,
but it was also the utility
that I got out of using it.
Simply by typing in a
URL, I got the same use
as if I tapped on-- as if I ran
Outlook or something like that,
right?
Except that now it available
everywhere and like
it just runs.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We've seen,
I think, for a lot of people,
Gmail has replaced their
desktop client for email.
And we've seen that
happen a lot in desktop.
So why aren't we seeing
the same in mobile?
What's in our way, Mike?
MIKE TSAO: So, I think there
are three main reasons why
the web versus data [? var-- ?]
where the web can improve.
First, obviously is performance.
And I think Ryan went into
a great amount of detail
yesterday about what
we're doing there.
We've got 60 frames per second.
And if we keep
doing our job, we'll
actually leave
some budget for you
to do some work within
that 60 milliseconds.
Capabilities, Alex is
definitely showing the path
that we're taking there.
Service Worker is going to help
a lot with the offline case.
And then on capabilities,
if Adrienne's work
with the permissions
API allows us
to bring some of the more
security sensitive capabilities
to the web, that's a good thing.
But also, once what you've
built this performance capable
app, what next?
And I think discoverability
or stickiness
or, I think, ease of recall--
is that the term that you
used yesterday, yeah--
those are the things that
are the difference between
an app that you've built
and an app that actually
other people end up using.
Because they can find it.
They can get back to it and
add to home screens, certainly.
Notifications, that's
another, more subtle way
of reminding people
that you're there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So why do we
need that stuff on mobile,
because we don't seem
to need it on desktop?
MIKE TSAO: I think we do.
I think we do.
I think that the web did well
with its strengths on desktop.
But mobile is something
that's with you all the time.
And sometimes there
are different contexts
when an app is more relevant
than it was on a desktop,
here, and certainly in
a mode of operation.
And I think that
we're beginning to see
some of the limits of
the web in that respect.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, we need
to add to home screen
on mobile, because
it's just really
hard to type URLs on mobile.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But we've
got add to home screen now,
so problem solved, right?
GREG SIMON: No.
First of all, it's
buried in the UI,
like you have to like tap
and scroll and find it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
But we're the ones
that have buried it, right?
We control the browser.
Why have we done that?
GREG SIMON: I can't answer that.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
I can give it a shot.
GREG SIMON: Sorry.
The other thing is most websites
aren't built to run offline.
They're built assuming you're
sitting at one end of a T3.
And this was OK 10 years
ago, when most of the web
was consumed on desktop.
But now, if you install
a Java app on Android
or a C app on iOS, you
take all the loading
hit up front, right?
And as soon as I tap it, it
just runs and just works.
The web, I'm not sure
if it's cached or not.
Or I jump into an elevator
and suddenly, I've
got 8 out of 10
resources loaded.
Oh, I can't use it.
ALEX RUSSELL: Just a followup.
Exactly what Greg said.
But it's also the
case that we haven't
had a strong signal until now.
That something is Appy.
We haven't known
that something is
going to work well as an app.
So it's the right thing to do
to leave the user in control
of whether or not to decide
that something should
be saved to their home screen.
But what we haven't done
or haven't given ourselves,
to date, has been the ability
to know that something wants
to be treated like
an application.
And so I think the
manifest format
and Service Workers together
give us that strong signal.
You've got responsive
breakpoints.
You've got a manifest.
You've got Service Workers.
You're probably an app.
And that's the sort of
signal that we can finally
use to raise the priority
of that kind of UI
and actually ask the user,
hey, this thing is an app.
You're getting a lot
of value out of it.
Do you want to keep it?
Do you want to have it
on your home screen,
without you sort of having to
divine, through use, that it's
one of these Appy-like things.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what's
the signal then for that?
Is it the frequency of
visiting or the amount
of time the user
spends on the site?
ALEX RUSSELL: We have
talked quite a lot
about a combination of factors.
And I think that the
strongest contenders, so far,
are the existence
of a Service Worker
and a manifest and
some amount of reuse.
Going to a website
once shouldn't get you
a prompt or an info bar that
says, hey, install our app.
I mean that's maybe the worst
part of the mobile web today.
And so, people talk to us
and they're like, well,
you're going to add a prompt.
And I go like, have you
used the mobile web?
Have you actually gone to
any websites on your phone,
because, if you do, you
are seeing a banner that's
worse than that all
the time, every time.
So we'd like to do better than
the status quo, which is that,
but only when users are
being engaged with something
that's valuable to them.
So I think that's going
to be the dynamic.
But again, we don't want
to gate the capabilities
and permissions that we were
talking about yesterday,
based on some sort of an install
for or some upfront grant,
where users have to
decide to keep something
to get a useful website.
If I go to an airline
website, I should
be able to have it notify me
later, in the background--
months later, maybe--
without me ever
having to decide to take up
some valuable home screen
real estate for it.
That's maybe something
I want to do,
but it should be
optional as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Cool.
So we'll take live questions.
Actually, there you go.
You're there.
You can ask a question.
Well done.
AUDIENCE: So one big
difference between native apps
and mobile apps, web apps, is
that you can ask permission
during the life of the use
of the application, where
when you install an app, right
now, on Android, for example,
you grant those ahead of time.
The thing is, if you had to home
screen now, all of the sudden,
you have the browser UI
that reads the peers.
And you don't have any mechanism
to go in and grant or revoke
permissions.
How do you plan on
solving issues like that?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: You
have a really good point.
That is a challenge.
And that's something that
we're actively working on,
and we'd like to change.
We have two
competing goals here.
One is to give the
app-slash-website as much
screen real estate as possible.
And the other is we do want to
have an entry point and a way
to ask the user for permission.
So I have to be honest.
We don't have a perfect
solution to this yet.
But this is
something that you'll
be seeing us working
on in the near future.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So if we
have an add to home screen,
are we going to also grant
some permissions there?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT:
That's a good question.
So we are looking at tying
some types of permissions that
are not privacy sensitive
to signs of positive user
engagement.
And I expect that
adding to home screen
will be one of those signs
of positive user engagement.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So when
we add to the home screen,
you get this kind of immersive,
full screen experience.
But I mean that's at the
cost of the URL bar, which
native apps don't have.
Isn't the URL an
important part of the web?
Andrew, with Cordova, you
don't have a URL bar, right?
I mean are URLs dead now?
Do we not need them anymore?
ANDREW GRIEVE: Right.
So say, with Cordova, you get
all the system integrations
for task switching.
So like, yes, you
can't refresh the page,
but you can easily kind
of swipe the app away
and restart it if you like that
URL bar for the Refresh button.
But you do actually
lose out on things
like being able to copy
and paste that link.
And it's actually,
I'd say, it's one
of concessions we
make to get ourselves
into the app stores is
losing that ability.
So I think it is
great how Chrome
is like getting rid
of the address bar
when you're scrolling.
But you always know
how to get back to it,
and that's a good thing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But with
add to home screen things,
we have lost it, right?
Are we happy with that?
ALEX RUSSELL: No, I don't think
we're necessarily satisfied
with the current state.
Between the question of
recall of site settings,
getting back to
permissions that you
can modify, to the
previous question,
and the ability to get
back to the URL bar,
I think those are things
that we want to do.
And the window treatment
that we showed yesterday,
for this desktop
standalone treatment,
is going to have some
affordances for that.
We still have to figure out what
that's going to be on mobile.
We don't have an
answer for that yet.
But it's a clear area
that we are looking at
and do want to improve.
ADRIENNE PORTER
FELT: I don't know
if you saw this
yesterday, in Alex's demo,
but there's a very, very
minimalistic URL bar
at the top, on desktop.
And one thing we're
exploring is figuring out
how to bring something
like that to the web, where
it doesn't take up as
much space or maybe there
are heuristics for when we
show it or don't show it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll take a
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Rachel,
from control group.
And we actually do a lot
of client products, where,
like this past year, I
did a Chrome Web App.
The hope was it could just
exist and not be supported.
Unfortunately, it also meant
locking down the version.
And I know this is
touchy, because I
know you guys like to make
sure everything's up to date.
And we did follow the
documentation for the set
interval, to
control, to make sure
that things wouldn't look
funky if there's a new W3C
spec for some kind
of CSS property
that would make
things look funny.
And yet it still updated.
So we ended up having to use a
crude proxy type of situation.
And I was wondering
if there was any plan
to allow those
kinds of permissions
for companies that really
want to own the app,
and it's not really
for the public use?
MIKE TSAO: We should
probably talk offline
about this, because
I'd like to find out
more about the specific
problems that you're having.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
MIKE TSAO: But
generally, I'd say
that we have this philosophy
with the open web,
if I can speak for
the entire open web.
[LAUGHTER]
When you add something
to the platform,
you [? can't ?] take it away.
And with very few exceptions,
we've kept that promise.
So if there is something
going on in the Chrome runtime
that you're relying
on for Chrome apps,
we should be in
touch and make sure
that we haven't had regressions.
That probably
wasn't intentional.
There are a few cases
where, oops, security issue.
We've got to do something.
We don't have a choice there.
But generally, if you're trying
to lock down the runtime,
that's probably a symptom
of a larger problem.
AUDIENCE: OK, we'll talk later.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So another
question, in inference.
So you were saying,
Service Worker
is going to be an
indication of something that
looks like an app.
For people who want to use
Service Workers soon-- I mean,
it's not on Android
at the moment--
what do people do to
be able to use it?
And even if it does
hit Android, when is it
arriving in other browsers and
what can we do in the meantime?
GREG SIMON: Well, It's in
M40, the first version,
in Chrome 40.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
does anyone in this room
have access to M40?
GREG SIMON: On desktop they do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
On desktop, right.
GREG SIMON: You can
build it from source.
You can build a content shell
from source and run it locally.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Get all of your
users to download the source.
It's only a few
gigabytes, right?
I mean you can do.
ALEX RUSSELL: There's also
a build of the content shell
inside the [? Polly ?]
[? repo ?] of the demo that I
showed yesterday.
That's all open source.
And there's a build
with an APK for that.
It's not going to auto
update, because it
is just content shell.
It's just a dummy system.
M40 is going to hit beta
for Android in, I think,
about two weeks, sometime
just post-Thanksgiving.
So look for that.
And that'll be your chance to
play with it on mobile first.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: This
is a temporary problem,
because it's on the M40.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, but desktop
is how you can get today,
Dev Channel or Canary
has it right now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
what about Safari?
They don't have an
implementation on it.
So I mean, people can't use
Service Worker until we've
got in all the browsers, right?
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
the thing that I
failed to mention
yesterday, and I
think it's implicit
in the model,
but I screwed up
by not mentioning
that Service Workers are
progressive enhancement
for the network.
They are a way for you
to take web content
and make it offline-able.
If you architect your
application correctly,
you should absolutely be able
to use the exact same content,
with and without
a Service Worker.
And because Service Workers only
install after that first load,
you sort of have strong
incentives to do that.
And Jake and I thought
long and hard about this
to try to make sure that
what we weren't doing
was creating a world of
spinners and loading screens,
where people felt like they
had to wait till a Service
Worker was ready before
they could do anything.
We want you to keep
building websites that
are friction-free and
ephemeral and just
work when someone
hands you a URL.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It
will be possible, when
you detect that a Service
Worker hasn't installed,
to show a spinner and then
wait for it to install and then
refresh the page, to kind
of create a sort of blocking
experience till the
Service Worker is there.
If you do that, I
will hunt you down.
GREG SIMON: The Service Worker
is a great example of an API
that is sort of like
an escalator, right?
When an escalator fails,
in turns into stairs.
When an elevator fails, well,
you're stuck on that floor.
And Service Worker-- I mean,
Alex took the Polymer/Topeka
app from I/O, which was
not designed for offline,
and added one Service Worker,
which is about this much text,
and it just worked offline.
It was just amazing.
Like I've never seen
anything like it.
ALEX RUSSELL: The way
Polymer sort of encourages
you to architect your
applications, by the way,
with it sort of loading a shell
and then you loading content in
and doing data
binding, is incredibly
compatible with this
sort of style of things.
Other frameworks are, too.
If you're using
Ember, if you're using
some of these other, taller
frameworks that sort of have
a data model on the client side
and are doing synchronization
about the data
model, you're going
to be in a much better
spot to take advantage
of these capabilities early on.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
And I think also,
with Service Worker,
as an end user,
it's so obvious when there's
a Service Worker installed.
It loads so much faster
in subsequent loads.
It works when you
go on the elevator.
And so it's like so
obvious to your end users.
And because you
layer it on easily,
I think the
developers are really
going to want to adopt it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll
take another question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: So I actually want
to roll things back, say,
two questions, kind of the app,
add to home, Cordova context.
From the developer's
perspective,
if I want to build an app
that's meant to work like an app
and wrap it up in
Cordova, I've already
taken care of
everything from my side.
So I can make sure the user has
a good experience, whether they
want to use a menu
button to share
or whatever behavior needs
to be added, that's there.
Right now, with add
to home screen--
I didn't even realize
this till last night.
I was talking to a user
that isn't technical.
You add to home
screen any website,
and you can create kind
of a bad experience.
It's hard, maybe a week later,
to share that with somebody,
because the URL
bar is not there.
The menu button
share is not there.
And I think about the
new web manifest concept.
Maybe that can be more
of a trigger to say,
if someone adds to home screen
any website that wasn't really
indicating that it was
meant to be used that way,
it's a little more of
a webby experience.
And as a developer,
maybe I can do something
with the manifest to
say, if someone adds this
to home screen or installs
my web app, that it behaves
more like an app as opposed to
it being assumed or inferred
so loosely.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I believe that
the URL bar is opt-out still,
right?
It's a meta tag
that triggers that.
But I think the problem
we had was that a number
of out-of-the-box
web starter kits--
maybe not the Web Starter Kit--
has that meta tag in there
by default, which is, I guess--
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
--part of the problem.
AUDIENCE: Because I picked a
random site when I did that
last night, so that
would make sense.
Thank you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
web apps are still
hamstrung by a lack
of capabilities.
When will get access to things
like media galleries, USB,
Bluetooth, and all
the good things
that you can get
on native programs?
I guess, Adrienne, it's
basically your fault, isn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, you want this
web thing to be "secure"
and not "harm users."
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT:
So first of all,
I really wish I
had an evil cackle,
because I would like
to use it right now.
Yes, it is our fault.
We're trying to
figure out a good way
to expose a roadmap for
exposing all these capabilities
without having negative
security and privacy impacts.
I think we're
making good headway.
We have stories for
Bluetooth, for notifications,
for getUserMedia, and
for many of the ones that
are coming up soon.
And we're trying to come
out with a generalizable way
to approach this
problem in the future.
But in the meantime,
there is going
to be a lot of
iteration, both in Chrome
and in other browsers, that
hopefully will get us to figure
out what the best approach is.
MIKE TSAO: And just one
thing to add to that.
The reason that we
chose web Bluetooth,
at this fairly early
stage in this effort,
is precisely because it's
a fricking scary API.
If you think about
visiting a website that
talks to your devices
that aren't even
touching your computer, that
is a really scary proposition.
And if we are able to crack this
nut, it's really tantalizing.
Because think of all
the other things that
are sort of lesser instances of
the same sort of class-- USB,
serial, NFC.
If we can do this without
breaking the web security
model, it's very promising.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: As I
want to remind everyone,
one of the reasons that you
have so low friction in the web
is that people aren't afraid
to click on the links.
And so it's really
important to maintain that.
That's one of the
really important aspects
of low friction on the web.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, I want
to just agree with that.
Because if you think about
how native applications work,
the correct model for
understanding the security
implications of a
native application
is that you've given the
developer of that application
a shell on your most
private compute.
You've given them a local
user account, basically.
And that's generally
an OK thing to do.
But that model is very
different to the web model.
And we're in a relatively
good place to start from.
We haven't given people
tremendously powerful upfront
grants that users can't revoke.
We haven't created APIs that
users don't have control over
or we can't give
users control over.
So as we extend these
new capabilities,
I think we're going to be making
even more work for Adrienne
and her team to help make it
easier to manage this stuff.
I know that a lot of that's
already coming in 40 and 41,
with better site settings,
like you shared yesterday
for revocation and
managing these permissions.
But as we roll those
out, those are all
going to stay
under user control.
And as a developer,
the onus is going
to be on you to make sure that
you handle the situation where
the user has either denied
or rescinded your privilege
to do it, just like Adrienne's
slide-show yesterday.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what do we
find people using Cordova for?
I mean, because surely this is a
great signal for what we should
be working on getting
into our web standard.
ANDREW GRIEVE: Yeah, it's
certainly a good spot
to check out what
people are using it for.
Actually, this is a little bit
of a funny question for me,
because I actually find most
Cordova maps are using it just
to get into Play Store.
They're not actually
using half the permissions
we've been asking for, which is
actually really annoying when
you install an app.
And another thing I thought
about, around these lines, even
access to hardware
sounds scary, but it's
really, in the grand scheme of
security, not all that scary.
Like I'm a bit more scared when
an app asks for my contacts,
like personal information
rather than my devices.
Because I could just turn
my printer off or whatever.
ADRIENNE PORTER
FELT: Security team
might have a slightly
different opinion.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW GRIEVE: So no,
I agree with all that.
But I was saying,
one of the things
about the open web
I think is scary
is like access to
your file system.
And so the browser
is taking a really,
I think, conservative approach
to this on the desktop.
And it's kind of worked fine,
for the most part, until now.
I think finding the right
solutions to this is important.
But really, taking that
conservative approach
is what builds
your user's trust.
It's really important.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I want
to come back to this.
But we'll take a question
from the audience first.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
One of the main use cases
to build a mobile web
app and the wrap
it into Cordova is
to have access with
maybe a single code
base to both marketplaces.
But still the offline
story is pretty bad even
in a Cordova web app.
You have to do a lot
of things yourself.
And so Service Worker Looks
like a fantastic way to do that.
So if I go all the
way down, and I
try to build a Chrome Web App,
and then I use CCA and wrap it,
is it going to work on iOS?
And how are we going
to get to that?
And even the app that
you've published yesterday,
so you use app cache also
to make it work offline,
because you can't use
Service Worker on my phone.
And eventually, if I'm on an iOS
and I download it as a web app,
then I suppose I can run
it in the Chrome browser.
So I need to use the
Chrome browser in order
to access those capabilities.
I won't be able to use Safari.
And then if I push
it in Cordova,
what's that whole story
going to look like?
ANDREW GRIEVE:
Sounds like you have
a really good understanding of
the current state of affairs,
actually.
So I mean, offline with
Cordova is, for most apps,
pretty straightforward,
because you just
pack all your assets there.
But I think the kind
of question here
is like, what are
we doing to try
to make Service Worker
maybe work in Cordova
or try to make Cordova
look more like the story
that we've been selling
this conference?
So that's a wonderful idea.
We are going to work on
seeing what we can do there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I got a
question in, from Twitter,
from Marcos Caceres at Mozilla.
The SSL certs are
still a problem
to obtain especially
for subdomains.
We're blocking a lot
of the APIs on HTTP
and making them HTTPS only.
What are we doing to address
the problem of making
it easier for
users to use HTTPS?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: That's
a really big question.
I want to acknowledge
that there has
been some pain in this space,
particularly if you want
to use scripts or resources
from other websites that
don't support HTTP.
But things are
getting a lot better.
For example, CloudFlare offers
free, universal SSL now.
And we are trying to build more
developer tools into Chrome
to be able to tell
you the status of all
the resources on your website.
And we are cognizant
of this and we
are trying to build tools
to help you with it.
But it is necessary.
You don't want your ISP,
the guy sitting next to you
at the coffee shop, you
don't want these people
to be able to use these
dangerous privileges.
So although there is a little
bit of pain that comes with it,
it is a really important,
fundamental part
of just being able to add
these new APIs to the web.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: One of the
native apps I use frequently
is a podcasting app.
And I wouldn't be able to
recreate that on the web,
because most podcasts
are served over HTTP.
I mean, are we lacking
pragmatism here with that?
Or is it bad that
native apps can do that?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT:
I actually think
that native apps, in
general, are not always
great about using
HTTPS when they should.
And this is actually a problem.
I think the web here, in
some ways, has an advantage,
because it's easier for the
user to see what the security
status of a page is,
whereas, in native apps,
that's often not the case.
Plus native apps
often try to use HTTPS
but perhaps don't
quite get it right
and actually validate
the certificate.
So in some ways,
I actually think
the browser has an
advantage in this corner.
And I'm hoping that
native apps get brought
to where we are right
now in the browser.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So are we out
to destroy native apps, right?
Or are there things that the
web will never be able to do,
so native apps will have
to be there for that?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
that question presumes
this is a zero sum game,
which is absolutely untrue.
So there's always going
to be some cases that
are really great
for native apps.
But we want to make sure
that developers have choice,
and they can use the
right tools for the job.
So again, if you're in
the torso or the tail
and you want to reach your
users as easily as possible,
the web is an amazing
option for you.
And we want to empower that,
like we did on desktop,
with more and more capabilities,
more and more power,
so that you can build better
and better experiences
while maintaining
that zero friction.
But it's fundamentally
not a zero sum game.
ALEX RUSSELL: Yeah, I sort of
think back to, even on the web,
like how we deliver experiences
across the entire range
of devices that you can
see out on the device wall.
The Google Search team delivers
dozens of different experiences
based on device capabilities.
Over time, they've got different
renderers, different pipelines
for giving you different
copies of the same 10
blue links with different
features attached to them.
And that's something
that you do when you're
trying to reach different
users at the highest fidelity
they can possibly have.
And so the question,
like you say,
isn't are there going to be
places for native apps or web
apps.
It's more like, how do you
reach that first set of users,
that largest first set of users
with your largest investment?
And then how do you reach
that incremental set
of users as your
application grows?
The web can be an incredible
reach and enabler for you
to get in front of more people.
But today, it has missed
some early advantages
in terms of UI access.
And so I think the
goal, for us, is
to make your investment in
your website a much more
attractive proposition, make
it so that you can reach more
of your users, more easily,
by building your website well,
and then figure out
what you're going
to do to reach that other set of
users in those other use cases.
That may involve a native app.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what
would the native app do that
the website can't?
What's that area
that is for native?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think you can
look at it like the things that
are available in Cordova,
for example, today
to give us a taste
of some other things
that you can do in
native apps today
that you can't do on the web.
And the web does trail some
of this stuff sometimes.
Because we have to figure
out the security model.
We have to figure out how
to responsibly bring it
to the web.
We have to figure out which
of these APIs that people have
pioneered in native is
worth bringing to the web,
or which of these are
just sort of dead-ends.
So there's always
going to be that thing.
If you want the latest
and the greatest,
you need access to the
absolute, most cutting edge
in terms of performance
primitives or what have you.
Native is a really
attractive option
if you're trying to squeeze
every last bit of it.
However, for the vast
majority of people,
what's really important
is reaching your users
and being realistic
about the fact that it's
very hard to convince people
to install your app, often.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, to just
go back to the question
that you asked there, Jake.
I mean, certainly a huge
advantage of the web
is that I don't have to download
30 megs before I have to login.
I can just, sort of,
like off the cuff,
load something and
be there, right?
But there's lots of things that
we can learn on the mobile web,
from apps, from
Java and iOS apps.
For example, web on desktop--
most desktop computers
are kind of the same.
Like they don't have a
vast arrays of sensors
that are very different.
They all have screen and a
mouse and like that's it.
But when you're talking about
mobile devices and watches
and VR headsets, it seems
like, every month, there's
some new piece of
hardware that, oh, jeez,
I really wish I had
an API for that.
But the web doesn't have
that kind of flexibility.
It's years to get
these sort of IDLs
in, whereas with a Java app,
you can just give them a jar,
and they can talk to the device.
So there are gaps on both sides.
And we're working on those.
MIKE TSAO: More on the
gaps on both sides.
I just want to emphasize that
native is not perfect either.
There are many
attributes of the web,
like linkability in particular.
You can't easily deep
link into an app.
Maybe Android intents
are one solution
to that or composability.
But I'm looking
forward to a time
when app developers aren't
facing this document-centric
versus app-centric decision.
And they're kind of
just saying, you know,
I'm going to go with
what works for me.
And then some apps, that happen
to be implemented on the web,
are going to take
advantage of linkability.
They're going to take advantage
of this fantastic ecosystem
that we have.
And at that point, the
native platform maintainers
are going to say, OK, yeah,
I agree, we are competing.
And this is an area where
we have to start competing.
And the competition
that I think is
going to come out of that will
be incredible, on both sides.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Before we take
a question from the audience,
I want to talk to the
rest of the audience.
What features do you
want most from an app?
All the things we talked about,
Bluetooth, whatever, that maybe
require permissions, if
you could have one of them
on the web, now,
what would it be?
Shout it out.
It's fine.
Great.
Should we just all go?
GREG SIMON: API versioning.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Come on, we'll
base our next year of work
on what you shout out right now.
AUDIENCE: Polyfill
for Service Worker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Polyfill
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Camera API.
What was the one over here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
More system control.
AUDIENCE: Push notification.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: What
was that, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Push notification.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Push notification.
GREG SIMON: Coming.
Soon.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll
go to your question,
because it might be the same
one that I've got written here.
AUDIENCE: Well, it might be.
So when are we going to get a
polyfill for Service Worker?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX RUSSELL: I have bad
news and bad news for you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, the
question we had from Twitter
is very similar.
Can Chrome on iOS
support Service Worker
before Safari on
iOS does as well?
And I guess that would be
in the shape of a polyfill.
ALEX RUSSELL: So, the
way to think about this
is that there is a
land before time where
you start typing a URL
into the address bar,
and then some user
agent gets a whack
at actually making
the HTTP request,
forming it, sending
it out to the network,
and bringing something back.
Polyfills, today, all
operate in the context
of the document that comes back.
Some script is executing
inside that document.
Service Workers,
and Gears before it,
were all about that
moment before time,
that moment before
your document even
exists, what it is that you
do to intercept that network
connection.
So before I joined Google,
we had built a little proxy
as part of a toolkit that I
had before that was actually
sitting on the user's device.
And it just ran a
little HTTP proxy.
And it basically
did the same thing.
And Gears did roughly the
same thing in the IE era.
And so those are solutions,
but those solutions
have to be relatively invasive.
So from a document, having a
polyfill for Service Workers
isn't going to work for
that first document load.
What you can do, however, is
to build your applications
in a way that's compatible with
Service Workers, where you have
an application shell, and
then you load content.
Today, almost every document
that we send down the wire
has expires headers
that are set to zero.
We cache all of our resources
but not that main shell.
Something you can do is
actually set that document
to go longer in the cache.
We don't do it today,
because it means
you can't keep fresh content.
But if you build your
application with a shell
and then a runtime inside
the shell, that's actually
checking the network to actually
go see if you can do stuff,
you may be able to get
some of that behavior back.
But you have to construct
your application
in a way that's friendly
for application centricness.
And once you're there, there
are some strategies available.
It's not a polyfill.
And we can't make you
one, unfortunately.
But to the Chrome for iOS
question, because Chrome on iOS
is actually there, mediating
between that document load
and what comes back,
it could, in theory,
run a JavaScript
context to mediate that.
It's possible for us to do it.
We haven't done it yet.
It's not currently in
M40 for Chrome for iOS.
But that's something
that we can look at.
GREG SIMON: We would really
love for Mobile Safari
to have this feature.
Don't get us strong.
We would really, really love it.
ALEX RUSSELL: Please
direct these questions
at your friendly,
local Apple engineers.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: A
good way do this
is build really
awesome experiences
that your users love and they
can point to and say, wow,
it works so amazingly well.
And it works on the elevator
on the subway in Chrome.
This is great.
GREG SIMON: Even
though we're hanging
all of these other APIs
off the Service Worker,
like push notification,
et cetera,
I still think that like
99% of the use of it's
going to be loading.
Because you can load the site
so fast with a Service Worker,
it's unbelievable.
So anyway, try it out.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So we talked
about the ephemerality
of the web being one of
the web's real benefits.
But if I've got like a local
to-do list or an email that
failed to send that's now in
an outbox or flight details,
I don't want those
things to be ephemeral.
I think the users will
lose trust in the web
if the browser ephemerates
their data away
on a whim, which is what
it kind of currently does.
So what can we do about that?
Greg or Alex?
ALEX RUSSELL: So we
have been thinking hard
about this problem in the
context of Service Workers.
When we looked at
the way that we'd
been dealing with persistence
for storage, to date,
we came away a little bit
unhappy with our former selves.
Today, there is only
one storage class
for a file system,
API in Chrome,
that can be marked
as persistent.
And that's a problem.
Because it means that your
application isn't constructed
just out of things that are
stored in the file system API.
It's constructed
out of JavaScript.
It's constructed out of markup.
It's constructed out of CSS
and a lot of other resources
that you may be holding onto,
index DB or some other storage
mechanism.
And today, those aren't durable.
And we don't really have an
API that lets us do that.
We've put together
a skeleton of an API
that would sort of let
you make an entire origins
storage durable, such
that it would be opted out
of the normal cache clearing
or evaporation of stuff
based on least recently
used heuristics.
And that's an API
that I think we're
going to continue to play with.
One of things that Service
Workers are going to let you do
is to understand what
is in your caches.
But again, I think,
in general, we
haven't done the strongest job
of making the amount of space
that's available on the
device available to you
as a developer.
And I think we're going to
continue to look hard at quota,
giving you more
of it by default,
making the quota
API more useful,
and giving you storage
pressure events,
so that you can
start to prioritize,
inside a Service Worker,
what you need to throw away
when you're under pressure.
So we're going to give you more
control and more visibility.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
So I think an API
like that, that's the easy
part of the problem, right?
I mean, it could
be even boiled down
to just a single function call.
But surely, the
hard part is sort
of how to communicate
that to users, right?
Like what are we
going to tell users?
Oh, this website is
now not ephemeral.
How are we going
to deal with that?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT:
I'm not sure I'm actually
the best person to answer that.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
so we have talked
about what it might
mean to have UI
maybe in this Keep action,
where we have offered
a website to you, to
say, hey, would you
like to hold on to this,
as maybe a strong sign,
as you were saying earlier,
about engagement and use that
might allow us to classify
an application as being
more important.
I think it's also useful
for us to have an API that
will let developers understand
the situation that you're
currently in.
And that's something that I
think we can get done quickly.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Because if
you, as an app developer,
know that they have stored
state in your application,
they would mad if
it was now gone.
You want some way to figure out
that you can alert the user,
hey, if you don't do
something, it's going to.
ALEX RUSSELL: One
of the things that's
critical about all these APIs is
that-- what you're seeing here
is that we're designing the
APIs to be asynchronous.
All these APIs are asynchronous.
All these APIs can fail.
And that means that
we're going to allow
users to be in control.
What that eventual UI is going
to be across different user
agents and browsers
is something that I
think we're going to spend the
next couple of years iterating
on.
I think we don't know
all the answers yet.
But I'm excited that
we can do is continue
to design these APIs that
have time built into them,
so that Mozilla can take
a different view of what
UI you should give, if
any, than maybe we do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I know when my
dad feels like his laptop is
running slow, one of
the things he does,
as part of his routine,
is sort clear everything
out of his browser, like all
the check boxes, off it goes.
Because he feels
like that's kind
of a non-destructive
action that's
going to somehow improve
the speed of his laptop.
But in a more appy web, are
you going to start losing data?
Is that going to be the
equivalent of him deleting
the system folder or whatever?
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: This
is actually a really good
question, because we want to
respect people when they say,
hey, clear my history,
blow away all the state.
And that's an important
thing that we really
want to do if that's
actually what the user wants.
But we have a sense that
sometimes people are doing this
not for privacy reasons,
but rather because they have
an idea that it'll make
their computer faster,
or they think they're
running out of memory,
but maybe they actually aren't.
So we're trying
to figure out how
to balance users' desires
with what they actually
want to happen in the end.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
one of the new APIs,
I think, people are asking
for and were certainly
excited about is having
push notifications.
So we've both [? sugarcoated ?]
in talks for here's
how you register
for push and here is
the event you'll get
in the Service Worker.
But what about the stuff
that's server to server?
Is that going to be standard
or are you just going
to have to deal
with a completely
separate communication
channel for if they're
talking to Apple, or if
they're talking to Google,
or if they're
talking to Mozilla?
ALEX RUSSELL: That's
another great question.
So today, the state
of the world is
that you send push
messages to devices.
And those messaging
services tend
to be tied to the
operating system
that the user is running.
And so, for instance,
for Android,
that's Google Cloud Messaging.
For iOS, that's APN-- APM?
I don't remember
the exact acronym,
but Apple's push
messaging system.
And so it's likely that
what's going to happen--
or for Mozilla, they'll have
their own system-- what's
likely going to happen is that
these, for some period of time,
are going to continue to be
device or provider specific.
Where you will get
a registration,
at your application,
about the registration
ID that comes from the device.
And you can know
what that device is.
And then you can have the
conversation with the back-end.
Today, all of those
protocols are different.
One of the things
that the team, that's
been working very
hard on this in London
and produced all the code for
the demo yesterday, have done
is that they've started
a standardization effort
around that server-to-server
communication channel.
Today, there isn't one.
And we're keen to get that done.
And I think everybody who's been
participating in this-- Mozilla
has been participating
in this process
with us-- is also keen to
see some sort of a backhaul
or a northbound
protocol standard,
so that we can
eventually get to a place
where your application
server may continue
to have to speak to
a different server,
based on what device
the user is talking,
but you don't have to
speak a different protocol
to talk to that server.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I
think at the moment,
we've got like a key in
the manifest, isn't it,
to sort of do--?
GREG SIMON: Yeah.
So that key is a
regrettable side-effect
of having to use GCM or
Apple's push system today.
And I think eventually
that can go away.
But we don't have plans
yet, in the initial release,
to remove it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We
ditched vendor prefixes
in both JavaScript
APIs and in CSS,
which I think was a great thing.
Are we sneakily
bringing those back
with meta tags and the manifest?
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX RUSSELL: So I actually
have a much different view
of vendor prefixes
than most people.
If you want no progress but
real stability, you can have it.
But you can't also
have new features.
It's important to
note that you have
to prioritize these incentives.
And so if you don't let
your platform breathe,
if you don't let it ever inhale,
it can never continue to live.
So it's important that we
find ways for our platform
to continue to breathe,
to continue to figure out
what the next features
should be and then
bake them in and
make them stable.
And so I think that vendor
prefixes have a bad rap,
because we have done
some of them wrong.
So for instance, with the CSS
vendor prefixes, we, Chrome,
shipped WebKit-, not
Chrome- or Google-.
And every other
webkit-based browser
did exactly the same thing.
So that was us.
It wasn't the vendor prefix.
It was a project prefix.
That was the wrong thing to do.
And I think it's good that
we've gotten past that.
As we do this in
the future, I think
we've been talking productively
with other browser vendors
about ways that we can
sort of, on a schedule
and for a limited set of
developers, break features,
so that you know that, if
you're using something new,
it's going to break.
It's going to change.
And I think that's a new
tactic that we're looking at
to hopefully enable us to zoom
ahead and give you the features
that you want.
But only if you're going to be
engaged in the process with us.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
Because obviously, the
prefixes were supposed
to be this warning sign
to developers like,
you can use this, but
it's not fully baked yet.
It might change.
But realistically, what
happened is people would just
learn that that was
the Go Stack Overflow,
just paste in this
thing and it works.
Great.
So it was hard to change.
GREG SIMON: When I think of
vendor prefixes and meta tag,
I think of browser vendors
trying to ship things faster.
Because there's a ton
of risk in being first,
as Dimitry said earlier.
And also, not many people have
the stomach for all the arguing
that goes on in all of
these standard scripts.
I mean, I certainly don't.
Alex does.
So when I look at
other platforms,
when I look at iOS, when
I look at Windows, when
I look at Android, the
web is the only platform
that must render everything
from the beginning of time.
Everything from Archive.org,
it has to be able to work,
otherwise we've somehow failed.
No other platform
has this problem.
And so it's very, very hard for
us to experiment and ship fast.
But we all want to
ship things faster.
And we are committed to
finding ways to do that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So with
well-built native apps,
one of the things I really
enjoy is I install them
and I run them.
And it's already able to
tie data to me, as a user,
even in the cloud.
Is that something we want
from the web, some sort
of like single identity
that the browser offers?
Or is that adding a kind
of centralization that is
anti-web?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: You
mean the centralization
is anti-web at the end.
So I think identity
is definitely
something that makes sense.
And we're investigating
how to do this correctly.
Because if you want to
opt in as a developer
and use that thing
that's already there
just to smooth over
the initial experience,
it obviously makes sense.
The way Android does it,
if I understand correctly,
is there are identity
providers on the system.
And for example, obviously
Google is one of them.
But Facebook also does it,
and others can as well.
And so it doesn't
necessarily have
to be that, if you're
talking to a native provider,
it has be like some
closed, centralized system.
You, as a developer, could
theoretically decide, hey,
this is the one I
want to go with.
I'm going to go with that one.
I'm going to just-- so.
I think that this is
something we are definitely
interested in.
We're looking at how
to do this correctly.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be something that's
like, well, you must
buy into this, the way
that this group does it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Sounds
like Web Intents?
Shall we start that again?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Maybe.
ALEX RUSSELL: So
one of the things
that I think maybe
you're alluding to,
Greg, is we're looking
at ways of having
a relatively small
API surface area that
allows us to expose more
capabilities more quickly,
but do it in a very
vendor specific way.
But not in the bad
way, in the sense that,
if I talk to your website, I'm
only talking to your website.
If I'm talking to you,
I'm talking to you.
I'd like to have a
conversation with you
not with some random
third party who
may be implementing
the same API.
That's a place where-- imagine
talking to a Service Worker
that Chrome has
implemented, but it's
only available at chrome.com.
That's the sort of
capability system
that you could have
over post message.
But it's just tied to an origin.
And we don't expect
web-hosted APIs not to break.
They break all the time.
It's just sort of what
happens on the web.
It's just content.
So that's the sort
of area where we
can imagine creating a
broader ability to launch
new features quickly and
maybe integrate deeper
with the underlying
system like Intents did.
GREG SIMON: Right.
But that moves from an
IDL binding to a protocol
binding, which is a
lot more flexible.
You can version it.
You can sniff to see if it's
there-- a lot more stable.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So if we're
getting all these cool
new toys, they're
going to have to be
behind some kind of extended
permissioning system.
Are we going to head towards
a massive in-browser spam
problem, where you
visit a site, and it's
going to be this site wants
to know your location,
it wants access to
your microphone,
it wants to know the
gender of your pets?
[LAUGHTER]
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: I'm
intrigued with the website that
needs to know the
gender of your pets.
I think if we were
to do nothing,
yes, that would happen.
But we are aware that
this is a problem.
It's a problem for everyone.
It's problem for developers.
It's a problem for users.
So we're taking steps
to try to prevent it.
So that's why I
mentioned earlier looking
at types of positive
user engagement
to figure out non-privacy
sensitive things a user might
wish to automatically
grant to a website
and also the inverse of that,
looking at crowdsourcing.
If a large number of users are
unhappy about a website having
something, maybe we shouldn't
be asking users about it.
Because we know they're
going to say no.
We're also looking at
things like setting up
smart defaults and
new types of UI,
like a choose-your-model,
where the user is selecting
from amongst a set of
things, as part of the flow,
instead of just answering
binary yes or no questions.
So we're taking
several approaches
to try to prevent the
info bar explosion world.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Is there something
we can do there to prevent the
Android problem, where there's
a big, long list of things
and people are like, yeah,
whatever.
It becomes the terms and
conditions sort of problem.
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: I think
actually the people sitting
here can help us with that.
I really hope that websites
don't try to work around us,
to be popping up long list of
permission requests on load.
I think that doing that does
the entire web a disservice.
So first of all, I don't
think it'll actually
work out in your favor.
I think people will say no
to that, because they haven't
gotten a justification yet.
And it also hurts the
user, because now,
going to every website,
it's immediately popping up,
without any context, these
questions that are scary,
and they don't know
how to understand.
So I like to hope that the
web naturally avoids this,
because it seems to
maybe not to be the best
experience for the web, for
websites to be doing this.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's
not a good experience
for that site in
particular, too.
I mean, the users are going
to be, why the hell is this?
They're going to bounce.
So it's bad for the
whole web if you do that.
It's also bad for your own
particular site if you do that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think a
good, bad example of this
is actually Google Web Search.
If you look at that on
the mobile, you go there,
you type in your search
thing, and it comes up,
Google wants to
know your location.
Is that fine?
I bet it would.
I'm not going to tell it.
But if it was a
button that said,
Localize Your
Search Results, when
I felt it would be relevant,
I might press that.
And it would go, Google
wants to know your location.
Yes, fine.
You will need to know that.
ADRIENNE PORTER FELT: We
have this problem, right now,
because, currently,
there's no way
to find out if you
have geolocation
without trying to use it.
So I mentioned in my talk
yesterday, the permissions API,
which currently both Mozilla
and Chrome are interested in,
which will help with
this type of thing.
Because you can check.
If you have it or not, then
you can use it on load.
And if you don't
have it, then you
should wait until the
user turns on a feature
or actually makes the search
before you ask the question.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So
what do we think
the way forward
here is in future?
If we do have
things like caching,
so we can get page load fast,
we have navigation transitions,
to get from one place to
another, in that future,
are we still going to
see single page apps?
Or do those other technologies
take care of that?
I guess, in Cordova,
what do you see there?
Because, I guess, with
the native platform,
you've got caching,
you've got transitions,
with your transition from
one web view to another.
Or do you still see people doing
all of that transition work
within a single web view?
ANDREW GRIEVE: So the
transition between pages
creates a nice visual
continuity for the user.
But under the hood,
it's basically
like you've closed your app
and you're restarting it again.
I think there's still going
to be that strong advantage
for single page applications
in that they don't have
to clear out their
entire JavaScript context
and restart from scratch.
If they want to
save anything, you
need to persist it and
then read it out again.
It's not a very good model.
I'm actually really interested
to see how these activity
transitions will be used,
because I think single page
applications have
a clear advantage.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
think the problem
with doing the single page
app thing is that, to do that
and to have correct URLs, which
you should, you sort of opt in
to the history state API, like
the push state, pop state,
and you're also,
therefore, opting
in to lower quality of life.
Because I've never
found those APIs
have really worked
correctly for me.
What do you think?
Is this something that
we're going to see go away?
Or this that going to be a
sort of deprecated model?
ALEX RUSSELL: I don't know
what's going to happen.
And I'm excited about that.
I actually am
incredibly excited,
because navigation transitions
and the team that's building it
are going to enable regular
content websites, people who
aren't building single
page applications,
who may not have the
engineering team, who may not
have the chops to
actually go build
the same sorts of experiences
with some of that lag, right?
So there may be an advantage.
But that's an advantage that
you can pay for as you go.
And I think that, if you have
a Service Worker installed,
it may be the case
that maybe you're
in the same ballpark in
terms of total performance.
We don't know.
I can't wait to find out.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We'll take a
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to validate what
you said a second ago about
the location and Google Search.
Anyone that knows
me knows I probably
am more Google connected
than half the Googlers are.
And I'm very trusting
of the platform.
And yet I found
that, subconsciously,
that's one thing
I've always done
is denied that location request
on the Search page, where
I would never otherwise
even think twice about it.
All my devices are
tracking me anyway.
So I think you got a
really good point there.
It's just the context.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
I think we really
need to keep hold of
the contextual part
of the permissioning
model, rather than go
to what Android does now.
Maybe even we can get Android
to come over to our side
and do things the right way.
How do we make sure that
web APIs in the future
aren't going to be constantly
a year or two behind what
operating systems have, what
native applications have,
such as things like Apple
Touch ID or the Apple Pay?
How can we bring those
kind of things to the web
without this kind of
massive lead time?
GREG SIMON: So Alex and I talked
about that a bit earlier--
and Mike, also.
Yeah, we have to find a conduit
to ship access to those faster.
The current IDL
conduit is kind of
cumbersome for that,
because it doesn't scale.
And so that's why
we're looking at things
like Navigator Connect.
But that's just the tech.
There's still the
permissions aspect, right?
I can wire up the USB
port to my browser,
but that doesn't mean I should.
MIKE TSAO: Another
component is just
coming up with all
the right primitives
to have these spec
discussions more quickly.
If Service Worker becomes the de
facto target for events, that's
one thing, stream
interface is another,
all of these different things.
And I think that we still have
to go through the spec process,
but we can just make it as
efficient as we possibly can
so that there's not so much
reinvention of the wheel
each time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Well, to finish up,
we've got a kind of
captive audience here.
What do you guys
want from developers
to help move the web forward
or to make your jobs easier
to move the web forward?
GREG SIMON: Please ask
other browser vendors
to push the web forward.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
guess, to me, a good way
of doing that is, if you
use Service Worker to make
your stuff faster, then your
sites are going to be faster
in Chrome and in Firefox,
when they adopt it.
And hopefully, that will
guilt the other browsers
into having to implement it
so they'll be faster, too.
OK, that's all we have time for.
[APPLAUSE]